Megan come uh mid January
2025 who will be president of the United
States and then I will let you
go I hate when people ask this because I
don't I know and that's why I'm doing it
because you got me on that other one
with the trump in the santis thing and
now we'll just have a clip out there
hanging
there um I'm gonna have to say Donald
Trump I just think I know I know we're
about to go through a year of indict not
indictments criminal trials and probably
convictions and maybe even the Rogue
judge who sends him into jail pending
appeal unlikely but
maybe Trump grows with every controversy
and I think it will be true this year as
well I've never seen the Republican base
so angry about something even the ones
who don't like him are going to try to
send a message that that kind of
electioneering that the Dems are doing
to him is not okay and Joe Biden over
the next year is likely to have a fall
or an impossible to ignore senior moment
and so I'd have to say Trump Megan as I
always tell you you're on the top of my
very short list of people who make me
think that there are sane people in the
world and we might exist in a couple
years from now uh I feel like I owe you
a bottle of tequila because of that
Trump desan this thing for do you have a
specific type or do I have carp lanch
here yeah carp lanch as long as it's
like you know white I don't want like
any of the yellow stuff like this low
brow something something elevated please
you want a
crystallo I'll take it send it my way
I've learned if you put an orange slice
in it like an orange orange rind not the
slice it changes the whole thing you can
have it over rocks without the caloric
mixers boom you're home as they say when
they're drinking tequila adios
[Laughter]
Amiga